You're here, are
n't you? It's just me who's rude to you, but what about
that?
As evidence of that, you can see a beautiful Macker, it's pitch
black, but it's like this.
I'm saying that, but that's a devilish declaration, so
well, I don't know that there's no telegraph north, yeah, yeah,
Bill I knew it, but
it's not close to saying that I don't look like a devil, ah, no, you make
that
kind of face  I
've always been serious and caring, and if there's someone in trouble, I can't leave
them
alone.
I don't want
to do it, just ask Tanya
I'm sorry about diabetes I don't
know what to do Arcade Really, what should I do?
I hate women every day for that reason
. Ah,
I don't know why, but I'm not allowed to keep a pet in my room
.
I think that's why it's allowed